رفضت ايران التعاون مع تحقيق للامم
المتحده في انتهاكات حقوق الانسان واسطه
حمله قمع ضد المحتجين
وسوط مجلس حقوق الانسان التابعي للامم
المتحده على ادانه القمع الدمويه وتشكيل
بعثه المستقله لتقص الحقائق في الانتهاكات
المزعومه لا سيما تلك التي ارتكبت ضد
النساء والاطفال
هذا هو جددت الخارجيه الايرانيه اتهامها
لواشنطن ودول غربيه بالوقوف وراء هذه
الاحتجاجات فيما قرر طهران استدعاء السفير
الالماني وسط خلاف ان ديبلوماسي بين
البلدين بسبب ادانه برلين لحمله القمر
في هذه الاثناء اداءك منظمه الامم المتحده
للطفوله اليونسف جميع اشكال العنف ضد
الاطفال في ايران ودعت في بيان لها
السلطات الايرانيه الى وضع الحد لجميع
اشكال العنف والكف عن حرمان الاطفال من
حريتهم كما طالبات النظام في ايران
بالامتناع عن استخدام القوه غير الضروريه
او غير المتناسبه ضد الاطفال الذين ينضمون
الى الاحتجاجات يشار الى ان ما لا يقل عن
63 طفلا قتلوا برصاص الامن الايراني خلال
الاحتجاجات
[تصفيق]
هذا يوصل الايرانيون احتجاجاتهم في شوارع
المحافظات الايرانيه رغم قوات الامن
الساعات الماضيه على المناطق الغربيه
خاصه في كردستان وسستان بلوشستان حيث
تصاعد قوات الامن من حملات القمع فيما منح
المرشد الايراني الضوء الاخضر
وفيما هذا الكرديه شمال غرب ايران قتل مئه
وخمسه اشخاص خلال الثلاثين يوما الماضي
بحسب احصائيات غير رسميه اثر حملات قمعه
لقوات الامن وصفت بالوحشيه ما دفع بمثل
المدينه في البرلمان الايراني جلال محمود
زاده الى الدعوه لمحاسبه المسؤولين عن قتل
المحتاجين بالرصاص بما في ذلك الرئيس
الايراني وزير داخليته كما استدعت السلطات
الايرانيه قياديين اثنين من التيار
الاصليحي بتهمه التحريض على النظام ولم
يتوقف في القمر بل امتد للصحفيين حيث
اعتقلت عناصر من الحرس الثوري مراسله
وكاله انباء اننا الايرانيه واقتادته الى
مكان مجهول بحسب ما اكد الاتحاد الدولي
للصحفي
اخر
[تصفيق]
الشارع
في اكراد في الخارج بزعم دوري لهم في
تاجيج الاحتجاجات الداخليه
من النيران الايراني
بعشرات الطائرات المسيره والصواريخ
البالستيه مواقع المعارضه في اقليم
كردستان العراق
خليل نادري المتحدث باسم حزب الحريه
الكردستاني اوضح ان نحو 19 عضوا من الحزب
قتلوا منذ بدء الهجمات الايرانيه في اواخر
سبتمبر
واتهم نادر السلطات الايرانيه بمحاوله صرف
انتباه المجتمع الدوليه عن الوضع داخل
ايران بافتعاله تلك الهجمات ضد الاكراد
فيما افادت المفوضيه العليا لشؤون
اللاجئين التابعه للامم المتحده ان
اللاجئين ايرانيين بينهم نساء واطفال
كانوا من بين ضحايا الهجمات الايرانيه
الاخيره